in this video we'll be talking about
miseria gunnery
this is a Heil video for USMLE step one
and in this video we'll be talking about
the Salient features of nisaria gonry
this is a particular bacteria that
belongs to a group of medically
important gram-negative cocci they form
coffee bean-like structures known as
diplococci and they are non-spore
forming Catalyst positive and oxidase
positive very importantly they are known
in context of gonorrhea a sexually
transmitted disease these is the
causative organism
now in this video we'll be talking about
the features of engineering then the
pathology and the Immunology associated
with ingonery infection
then diagnosis and treatment of
gonorrhea
features of in gonorary
Nissan
negative organism they have thin cell
wall that is why their cell wall cannot
reach in Crystal Violet and they counter
stain with pinkish saffronine and this
is how they look like in a microscopic
slide here you can see some neutrophils
which are heavily infested with this
particular in gonor you can see these
dots they are the inconry
so in gonry is fastidious and grum
negative
they are facultatively intracellular
they cannot live outside the cell they
grow and multiply inside the cell
typically they appear in pairs so they
are generally diplococci
also they are capable of moving very
fast with twitching kind of Mobility
they are obligate aerob that means they
require oxygen in order for them to grow
so question is where does Nissan belong
in the microbial world if we classify
the Free Living bacteria with the help
of gram staining classification then
they are grum negative bacteria they are
gram negative cocci and under that we
can find two important species of
nysaria the nisaria gonorary and nyseria
meningitis one the first one is
responsible for the sexually transmitted
disease gonorrhea and the second one is
important for meninges infection now
we'll be focusing on nisseria gonry but
how it is transmitted it can be
transmitted by unprotected sex multiple
partner during pregnancy or even during
blood transfusion
the incidence of nyseria gonorary
infection is increasing day by day
throughout the world which is pretty
much concerning
when it comes to symptoms of Gonorrhea
there could be abdominal pain discharge
from penis and vagina there could be
painful urination Etc
now nisseria gonry can dock onto
epithelial cells with the help of their
pili and omp2 protein and this
facilitate the bacteria to dock into
several epithelia like urethra cervix
rectum or even conjunctivita
and it can modulate the immune system
let's see how immune Escape happens in
case of engineering
so in quantity has pili which protects
them from being phagocytes by
macrophages or dendritic cells they can
also secrete a protein known as
IGA protease that can cleave the IGA
antibody and save them from the humeral
immune response they can block the
complement system they can suppress the
th1 and th to subpopulation of T cells
and they can induce the th17
subpopulation of T cells which triggers
inflammation and neutrophil mobilization
neutrophils are themselves invested
heavily by by engineering and It
ultimately lead to burst of the
neutrophil and death of these neutrophil
which alleviates the overall infection
in gonry has several modification in
their surface adhesion proteins which
can prevent the alternative and the
classical complement pathway and that is
how one of the innate defense system is
kind of disarmed for the cells
now it can modify the activity of
different phagocytotic cells for example
the macrophage can basically uptick
these in gonry but the phagosome
failed to destroy the ingornery same for
neutrophil neutrophils are also
phagocytotic they can uptake these
bacteria but they cannot destroy them
generally neutrophil and macrophage
undergo a process known as oxidative
burst in this case they destroy these
pathogens with the help of reactive
oxygen species
now n Connolly has developed mechanism
by which they can counter the reactive
oxygen species and protect themselves
also it can be detected by specific tlrs
and instead of secreting
pro-inflammatory cytokines and sometimes
they also secrete cytokines which are
anti-inflammatory and they prevent the
dendritic cells activity and they
prevent or they suppress the dendritic
cell such that they cannot activate
other T cells so in coronary has
plethora of ways by which it can evade
the immune response which is pretty
fascinating at the same time it is
pretty dangerous
let's talk about the diagnosis of
ingornery
so in this area garnery could be
isolated using their Martin media it is
a modified chocolate agar media which
has a antibiotic cocktail so it has
vancomycin nyastatin and choleistine
now more accurate diagnosis can be made
via PCR based test from the urine so
basically it is more sensitive quick and
the problem is it is costly cannot be
used in every Health setup but it is
very accurate
also there are ways by which one can
understand inguinal infection let's say
there are purulent discharge from the
vigin or penis and they can put a smear
of it and Gram stain it so gram positive
gram negative diplococcus should be
visible in the slide but sometimes it
could be misleading as well so always
PCR based methods or Elisa based methods
are much more sensitive in terms of
detecting the infection
now let's talk about the treatment
gonorrhea so who prescribes uh safe
tracks on injection for this kind of
treatment and it's an intramuscular
cephalosporine antibiotic so these are
bacteria obviously they would be treated
with antibiotic CDC recommends a dose of
500 mg intramuscular
injection for this particular drug and
it will stop the infection but it would
not repair what has damaged right so
anything which was damaged due to this
infection
it would be still there but no new
damages won't happen
because the bacteria would be dead so
overall the rapid diagnosis of this
particular disease is important and
quick treatment would ensure better
recovery
anyway there could be the infection so a
follow-up after three four months would
be highly advisable
the concerning Factor about nisaria
gonorary or overall gonorrhea is it
shows highly variable antibiotic
response and there are specific reports
which shows that the overall response
towards antibiotic differs within
ethnicity and geographical area and this
area gonorary is actually gaining
antibiotic resistance which is a very
difficult for the clinicians because in
future it would be very hard to treat
with
anyway scientists are trying to
understand what is the basis of these
antibiotic resistance and how to
overcome this problem but I hope this
was well informative and good enough for
us Emily in summary we looked at the
common sexually transmitted disease
gonorrhea which is caused by n gonorary
we looked at the overall symptoms pain
etc for in context of gonorrhea
so gonorrhea can occur in both men and
male and females we looked at how it is
treated we looked at what are the
diagnosis options Etc so get more notes
and flashcards in my Facebook page or my
Instagram page all the links are
provided in the description you can
support our Channel using super thanks
and see you in next video
thank you
[Music]